let's get our heads back into space
because it was last week we were talking
about this few days of mass domain and
range was the idea it may arrange the
idea because we're thing about functions
like functions like this I read this as
Y is a function of X meaning that if I
know what value X is I'm going to put a
next number in and I'll get a y-value
out right good morning okay so I've got
inputs and I've got outputs yeah now
this idea of domain and range you're
probably good morning I guess I'll edit
that up later yea jus domain and range
simply means what inputs can we put in
right that's X values right X values
that we can put in that's what domain
means and range which is what we're
going to carry on with this morning
range is one of the Y values that we can
get out right what Y values are possible
now if you recall there were a couple of
examples of different kinds of functions
that we have met that caused problems
for our both of these right but we
looked at the X values that's what we
focused on okay so quick example just to
get your head back in session we're
going to dwell on this too long right if
i gave you y equals whatever x okay so
this is the standard hyperbola in fact
um the technical term is it's a
rectangular hyperbola let's do it of
strange trailer good morning just get
out that way and took a seat around that
corner all around chairs yes take this
one you seriously don't have actually
injured what if you can take this one
and then all right and I said
explore who I'll give you my keys just
go into a klm and just grab a chair turn
it clockwise um whatever X what does it
look like what is in the funny looks
like this guy right now importantly for
the idea of domain I can't put x equals
0 in there I can't put it in ya so what
that corresponds to the fact that i had
this asymptote at x equals 0 i know i
have a horizontal asymptote is over we
will do that in a second ok I can't put
anything into this that makes the
denominator 0 because I can't divide by
0 yeah in the same way just to extend on
this if you have anything that's in this
form where you've got X's an error on
the denominator ok for instance let's
look at a tricky reasonable here example
2 if I haven't the denominator something
like 2x plus 1 this will have exactly
the same problem there's a particular
value of x that if I throw it into this
if i try to input it then the
denominator will become 0 and my
function explorers um now help me work
this out right what value of x will I
put in here that makes the denominator 0
is it gonna be it's nice way to solve
this I'll just say there's the
denominator 2x plus 1 right and to find
out where these breaks I'll just make it
equal to 0 let me test this out this is
just an equation it's a simple equation
2 how will I solve it so I want to give
me a suggestion good morning we're gonna
need another chair um led on i do wanna
put your things down and then is it
still not or did you lock it out I can't
that's good um put your things out and
then go next door
hey no you're still okay taking the
school and so okay now how do you solve
this come on someone can be a first step
what will I do to both sides I'll take
one over to the other side or
alternatively i'll subtract 1 from both
sides same thing and then i divide by 2
which gives me this now what does this
mean okay what this means is if I put
that value in then the denominator will
be 0 I'll get 1 divided by 0 which is
what I actually don't want okay so it so
happens that what does this graph look
like it looks just like the one I just
showed you with one subtle difference
see this vertical asymptote where I
can't go right instead of being at x
equals zero like this one this one will
be at x equals negative a half right and
more or less everything else will look
the same but something like this and
something like this okay now keep in
mind right domain means X values that I
can input not the x value so that I
can't okay so on the basis that I've
found where I can't go how would I write
how would I stay how would I articulate
what the domain actually is we had a
look at it last time okay good I can go
less than to the left of this you know
ha so I'll say x is less than negative a
half that's just one side I can also get
everywhere to the right yeah which means
not less than but greater here okay or x
is greater okay let me just put a tiny
tiny note on this that you should take
all you should not say and even though
this you know it's hardly any difference
between those two words um but the
reason why you don't say and is because
there's no number in the universe that
is simultaneously less than negative a
half and also greater than negative a
half you're either one or you're the
other may exclude each other yeah so
that's why we use the word okay I'm
going to push on this just a little bit
before I go to the square root you can
see
anytime I've got a fraction like this we
call these rational functions because
rational just means a ratio that's a
fraction okay anytime you have a
fraction like that the denominator can't
ever be 0 right so let me give you
another trick your example how about
this guy okay now this is starting to
step up a little bit right we spent a
lot of time on quadratics and Fabolous
before I can tell you right now this is
not a parabola I'll show you what it is
in a bit but there's a quadratic here of
the denominator now what have we learned
from these first two examples here right
I don't want X to be 0 that will explode
thing I don't want two x plus one to be
0 that will also explode so what
conclusion do you draw about this guy
yeah I or we'll find it I don't want the
denominator x squared minus want to be
zero so let's see what happens let's
test out what happens in that case okay
if x squared minus 1 were equal to 0
this is the value I'm trying to avoid Oh
saw this dude it's a quadratic what
you're doing this rages ok so I've got
two choices right we'll go this way i
can go x squared equals what I'll take
that over the other side and now I've
got just x squared i take the square
root of both sides yes so that gives me
with x on the left hand side what does
it give me on the right it's the square
root of 1 which is one but don't forget
there are two numbers that I can square
that will give me 1 plus what I can
square u 1 and negative 1 can be squared
to give you one so our two solutions
okay so alternatively so this is option
one alternatively I could just leave x
squared minus one over there on the left
and I can factorize this guy i can use
difference of squares right that's a
square number that's a square number so
one of the factorizations you learn
earlier this year in products and
factors is this guy right this is
difference of squares I can go over
another
some more details but suffice to say
that this is the factorization of that
and this is well when we factorize
quadratics the point is you make one of
them 0 then you make the other 10 so i
get the same pair of solutions here now
what does this mean what what have I
just determined these values here like
yeah and like like a here these are the
values where my function breaks where I
can't put in those inputs okay because
it will make the denominator 0 okay so
therefore what this thing actually look
like well now this is a to be sure this
is outside the scope of what you need to
know now but it just takes this idea you
already know and extends it a little bit
in each of these cases there was one
place that I couldn't go one place there
was off limits from the domain but now
I've got two so I'm just going to draw
them both in I'll put plus one here x
equals one and I'll put negative one I
guess it'll be on the left hand side of
the axis okay some weight like that now
what does that mean where else am I
going to go well we actually have enough
tools to work this out really quickly I
think about if i put in a value to get
the y-intercept what values do you put
in to get the y-intercept you put in x
equals zero so if i say x equals zero
here or get 1 over negative 1 what's 1
over negative 1 it's just negative 1 so
then we want something like that one
okay um I know if I put in really
enormous values for X right like I'm
trying to work out where it's going
through the right like a million or a
billion or agree or whatever you put in
a huge number can you see that the
denominator is going to get enormous
right it's going to be a really really
big number if the denominator in
fractions really be what does that mean
about the whole number the whole number
is actually very small by like one over
a million tiny number whatever billion
is an even tinier number so therefore
what about you doing is I'm
coming towards zero like so I'm going to
have something like this in here and I'm
going to get this guy over here and
that's weird Alex really really read it
okay you don't need to know how to graph
all of that I can show you how to get a
computer to do it but the important
thing is i can state the domain of this
I know the X values that I can import
our know the one Scott let's just go
from left to right let's take this part
over here over here I can go to the left
of this value do you see that so that's
X is less than negative 1 that's part of
the domain that works my graph exists
for all these spots right that's one
section what about in here well how
would you describe this part of the
domain oh it's between negative one
right between negative 1 i've got to be
bigger than that but i also have to be
smaller than positive ones see that like
so so this is my way of writing negative
ones smaller than x which is smaller
than one okay I'm nestled in between it
ok there's the left there's the middle
and then of course I've got one last
section over here on the right how would
I say how to describe that part X is to
the right which is bigger than positive
one okay now I've got more pieces but
that's okay that's just all the bits
where I can put x value it's this or
this or this okay that's what happens
with domain when you got a fraction like
this